okay Victoria right yes um I was burning
ocean my mom having the ocean no in the
ocean she was swaying yeah she having
the ocean like a real live mermaid yes
I'm going to raise here in Kelly on a
trike a girl no I only have one parent
my mother does young what I know is I'm
gonna have my father left when I was
four months um all I know about my
father is that he was that he's a
ex-navy seal he looks like that he looks
like a black I was Presley he's six foot
seven and he's got nine sisters that's
about the only thing I know that Alan I
know his name I grew up very hard
actually I'm the oldest out of six I got
four younger brothers and a younger
sister
they were very sheltered in and-and-and
covered I was not I'm like the black
sheep I know I learned to know it more
than they did they know especially about
our mother my mother was a toughest
answer for 16 a half years so I grew up
in it in the field of entertainment
entertainment I was molested when I was
four by my brother's dad I've always
been the brave type though I've always
ridden to protect her my family yeah but
I guess you could say a backbone you
know I grew up with my mother and my
grandparents and
sometimes I talk talk with my hands
because that's my first language I can
sing in sign language I feel that I've
lived a
and like that wasn't mine I grew up very
fast for my age very very fast and to me
I feel like I've done almost everything
in the world except for taking life and
given life I have no children my own I
adopted my little brother when I came
back um the state of California had took
me away with my mother says they said
she was on fit mother which was not true
she was a very fit mother
she just had problems everybody else you
know um all her only pal was that she
was alcoholic and she claims to the
fullest she was not ashamed of it I was
very proud of it and that's one thing
hands there from my mother I'm very
proud of myself
and she's very glad she told me before
she passed it'll be a year this January
6 that she's been gone she was dead she
told me that she was very proud of me
and that never changed if I'm gonna
change change for myself and no one else
and stay the person that I am stay that
stay Who I am say who I stay the way out
I grew up off and on with my mother and
from foster home to foster home
gruberman a group home
my brother switch has had their fathers
so they were allowed to go home to their
fathers I was doing when I was left in
the system so I grew up in I grew up in
the city in the system they called me a
chronic relapse I mean I can't a chronic
runaway because I ran from every home
every trip home every house every every
foster home every coupon they put me in
I left I took off ran home always going
home I believe on the weekends so that
way I could spend a week with my mom and
knew that was a week off but in one day
or something so yes I ran away to going
home
yes I'd run away to go home they put me
they put me put me anywhere and is where
I still no on my way home always no home
but I'm a survivor you know we have
money in our family my mom my mom grew
up from a very wealthy family but she's
the type where she don't depend on my
family for money we make our own we get
our own you get your own you make your
own because it's better to have your own
it's not good to always depend on your
family you know his family's not always
there when they need to be I'm a very
very big family person
I'm big on traditions and traditional
thing is like I have to do a housing a
house you know traditionally tradition
raised I grew up on both sides of the
fence
as far as good and bad half my family
Jehovah's Witnesses you know have
practice magic I'm not religious I'm
spiritual I'm very spiritual I believe
that everything that happens in life
happens for a reason
and it's a part of a journey and the
reason that we're all here for we don't
know what we're here for but we're here
for a reason and maybe to change the
world or improve the world or half the
world or you know something I'm a
happy-go-lucky person I see the good in
everybody no matter if they're evil and
bad I still see the good and I'm some
way somehow
Oh weird I'm an awesome interest
I don't like submitting to nobody my mom
you say it's a little bit jealous in me
she will make sure that you listen
anybody at all that's true I don't like
listening to money I would always wanted
to go to the army under Navy or the
Marines but my mom said it wouldn't be
good for me because I would be dad just
I'll be just discharged because I talk
back and you know they're not allowed to
do that
I got him off of me my mom I'm always
say yeah I got a mouth like a sailor's
wife
cuz I'll cuss you out in a heartbeat but
I grew up I grew up I grew up learning
annoying ways that I feel that maybe I
shouldn't have but then I should have
learned anyway
me personally I'd rather I read her lips
make the world a better place
and make it a horrible place I'm really
into kids I love kids
I love teaching kids okay um happy was I
start getting high right um so my mom
had to win my mom had got real sick and
ended up in the hospital and it was just
me and the baby inside this hotel where
it wasn't frightening but it was just
disturbing you know me I'm not I'm not
I'm not scared I'm not scared anything
I'm not I don't fear anything
I'd like fear in the face and I tell him
I've faced my fear I [ __ ] my fear I
fight my fear I defeat my fear that's
how I look at it I like death if your
interface everything I'm [ __ ] you suck
my click sorry for words but that's what
that's how that's how I live like that's
how I look at it I don't care what
happens anything that happens don't do
nothing to my family or to I don't care
what you do to me just don't hurt the
ones that I love because you hit the one
that I love and you really have [ __ ]
over just remember your consequences or
repercussions [ __ ] wrong with me you
know
I may not be all that I may not be a big
and high mighty but
I know how to protect myself and I got
God on my side always I smoke crack II
cush yep I say CC riding connor careful
a little bit of everything a little bit
everything I'm a jack of all trades I
hustle hustle hustle very well I do have
a couple hustles I serve I trick a fake
my original thing before I was a prison
I was an adult entertainer party
planning organizer I would plan and I'd
plan parties and create parties for
adults for just so many reasons either
they wanted to learn how to get high or
they wanted to get high with a girl and
I provide that I said I'll look for them
and I just got paid it was a party I
planned a party for them that's all I
did you know and I wouldn't I go back to
that but if you didn't if you think it
hi I would I would mess with you if you
were all my clients has to get high I
don't care what you do you have to you
have to indulge in some kind of mine of
stuff Dean's a substance you have to get
you have to indulge with something I
don't hear what it is alcohol whatever
it is out of here you have to indulge us
something I also I'm not messing with
you that's just the way I feel this is
where I am personally I get high I'm at
it I'll fight fake the funk I'm proud of
it I don't deny it
I'm not gonna get it or nothing I regret
anything I've done in my life anything
I'm not ashamed of anything I've done in
my life I hold my head up high that's
what my mom always taught me you
everything had was ready for a reason
everything happens for a reason
and I'm never gonna be ashamed of
ashamed or guilty of anything I ever do
in life because that's what was about to
happen I take that back I got one thing
I'll regret one thing one thing one
thing and that's getting - I hit that's
it
childhood the events in your childhood
kind of led you to this right
I think the yeah I've been down here
since 99
it's what 2019 now yeah yeah 20 years
Wow well I was 19 well it's me when I
was down here so yeah I was still like
everyone thought I was a child I went
that I was like 13 14 years old but I
wasn't I was 19 I don't got one of the
only girls down here that was doing my
thing right I had a lot of jealous
people a lot of haters because for one I
got high and supposedly that drug is
though is it is is a dirty messed up
drug it's a disgusting drug well if
that's case then it wouldn't be a rich
man's high because every rich man gets
high on cocaine or crack I don't care
what you say they do they get high on
cocaine or crack one or the other it's a
rich man's drug that's what it is
but you ain't got to be rich to do it
yeah I love getting I love getting high
I do I love it it helps me bury my
feelings the house week it helps me numb
my feelings I don't like feeling and you
can't have feelings and emotions on the
streets anyways feelings and emotions
get you [ __ ] up and healed so I kept
my feelings on my underneath for a long
time but when my mom passed it's hard
now it's hard to keep a grip on my
feelings even getting high
I find myself
coming back to life more now I guess the
whole time when I was I mean I hear I
basically yeah I died I died my little
my son my stepson my little brother who
I adopt it when I was 18 when I first
was young my mom had I had to have
another child and she asked me to come
back and taking custody of him before
that way the social services wouldn't
get him right so I did I took it she I
took I seen him at six months old as
soon as I got off the plane from Chicago
my mom put put that baby my hands and
she's like that's yours that's your baby
you know got had okay it's that's your
baby so that's what that's that's that
was gonna be that was my baby you know
his dad kidnapped her for me and I lost
it I literally felt something come
inside me I ripped my gut out when he
crossed the border with him I know where
he was for three years and that's what
basically got me to shut down it's where
I let drugs take over cuz I was
graduated [ __ ] do not let me get sober
and pictures do not let me get single
cuz I will take over seriously if I was
to stop eating hi I'm not I'm not gonna
do a lot of things still without getting
high but I'd rather choose to get high
and just learn how and relearn how to
discipline yes yes yeah you're not
falling pushed yeah good on ya cuz they
almost a bit to me they almost did
that's me they are they they tried but
it wasn't going down um well to be
honest the baby and I found a dead body
once but I don't
hearing about it more than once seen it
and the witness in it
not at all I see it a witness if I was
gonna be one because I almost jumped up
jumped out the window
myself when the baby yeah you know for
me I I literally almost jumped out the
window and my friend taught me about my
ankle and I busted my chin on her ass
cry right here but yeah I literally
tried to jump out the window when that
happened um I don't want to live I
thought my baby was gone so who wants to
live without the child you know even
though I didn't have him I felt you know
I felt everything that an actual mother
would feel if they were is a Gabrus for
the chip child you know I mean I mean
that baby Leah my brother was so close
to me the baby were so close he was my
kid he's my son you know he called me
[ __ ] mommy you know he knew who his
mother was though he knew our mother was
our mother and he knew that I was you
know his sister but he called me a [ __ ]
mama because I was like his mommy you
know I did everything for him are you
miss for his birthday everything I was
dressed up like a damn clown for his
birthday okay no um he's a prison for a
murder I told I said mark my words I
said he lives with his father he's going
to either end up dead or in prison by
that time is 18 sure enough his 17th
birthday he stabbed his girlfriend 17
times to death
you
you